Caption: okay good afternoon everyone my name is
Caption: Ashley akin and this morning we saw some
Caption: cool technology is cool discussions from
Caption: Nigel this afternoon I'm going to do two
Caption: - I think is a really cool architecture
Caption: for enterprise system so I'm really
Caption: excited that this just as much as my
Caption: other than just as much of the VR and so
Caption: forth but to start with this talk is a
Caption: CQRS
Caption: and it is sourcing for the win hi my
Caption: name is Ashley a presentation from you
Caption: know lately I think this is a really
Caption: interesting architecture very important
Caption: architecture and I think that even if
Caption: you start with the different
Caption: architectures the rate of resistance you
Caption: actually end up getting something like
Caption: this while doing all the things
Caption: necessary to make it succeed so one of
Caption: the startup is something like tinder
Caption: anyway just for you know idea you know
Caption: the audience is like and who's heard of
Caption: the CQRS an event sorting a loon as you
Caption: used it ok quite a few all right that
Caption: helps me out with the audience there I
Caption: predict a similar talk before on this
Caption: but I got to early in the first half or
Caption: so so I'm focusing on the second half in
Caption: this once the holes are going to run
Caption: through the first part quite quickly you
Caption: think you'd love to see diffs I haven't
Caption: learned much about this and to give you
Caption: the context it can be a quite a complex
Caption: architecture don't wanna actually get to
Caption: the core essence of it I don't need it's
Caption: too hard really so the public's willing
Caption: to actually overdo okay wanting a CQRS
Caption: CQRS and event sourcing then we'll get
Caption: the final section which i think is
Caption: really cool about persisting application
Caption: safe for many of the aeration database
Caption: has been a core our persistence because
Caption: of the many reasons I'll talk about of
Caption: course no SQL command question things
Caption: there I think maybe we have an even
Caption: better solution for persistence so this
Caption: is me a computer scientist I work in
Caption: professional training academic software
Caption: development principle at running code
Caption: productions which sort of helps out in
Caption: enterprise applications but these are
Caption: also focusing on innovation innovate
Caption: leave calm my focus on applying Lean
Caption: Startup techniques and principles to
Caption: enterprise to helping companies innovate
Caption: by using these techniques at startup
Caption: shoots very interesting stuff and also a
Caption: more on the Java side
Caption: rather than they don't me and scholar is
Caption: you seen it it's a little bit Williams
Caption: command clearing this multi bility
Caption: segregation where the component and what
Caption: problem is it solving I guess you should
Caption: ask we have all bit of traditional empty
Caption: air architecture something like this you
Caption: know we have that the presentation
Caption: layers and the business layer which is
Caption: often in the hollows of application and
Caption: epoxy at the top and we have the
Caption: relational database down the bottom and
Caption: this scales in many ways you can have
Caption: lots of many presentation layer
Caption: instances here and many back ends
Caption: looking relational database but there
Caption: are problems and one of the problems is
Caption: it's difficult to scale this relational
Caption: database we can do sharding because the
Caption: mirroring that's all complex and you get
Caption: issues with transactions and so on so
Caption: there's a problem them to help us back
Caption: and made it difficult to scale other
Caption: problems with this approach well it's
Caption: pretty unbalanced we think about it most
Caption: of the application usually is read size
Caption: they're clearing the application to find
Caption: information with enterprise applications
Caption: with large applications not so much
Caption: writing or changing things but it is one
Caption: stack just for everything so it's really
Caption: not meeting the needs of both of these
Caption: sides
Caption: differently I mentioned is difficult to
Caption: sale because of racial database and we
Caption: may need different stores through our
Caption: different models what if you want to
Caption: have a grass database to store your
Caption: grass stuff and a relational database to
Caption: the document database can even manage
Caption: those on the back end have you handle
Caption: transactions across those multiple data
Caption: stores some of the possible solutions we
Caption: have these days are things like two
Caption: phase commit and three phase commitment
Caption: just atomic transactions and they get
Caption: very complex and very difficult and slow
Caption: and can't really scale to email demands
Caption: that our enterprise applications and
Caption: consumer applications in the 21st
Caption: century so this is y CQ RX k a lot how
Caption: can we solve these problems our
Caption: traditional architecture dozen able to
Caption: cope with the scaling needs of our
Caption: current business demands so if the root
Caption: of the CTRs approach goes back to object
Caption: orientation and a much more bertrand
Caption: meyer but speaking at architecture meet
Caption: when we talked about this all needs to
Caption: do objects and classes we said what
Caption: objects should have
Caption: things called properties which give you
Caption: some information about the object
Caption: measure have operations which change
Caption: something in the objects but you
Caption: shouldn't sort of mix these things you
Caption: should keep them separate so the glue
Caption: object either design principle that I
Caption: taught for many many years and this
Caption: principle now I'm going to transform it
Caption: apply it to our architecture of our
Caption: systems our enterprise systems and see
Caption: what it does so again here is simplified
Caption: form in our traditional n-tier
Caption: architecture presentation layer business
Caption: layer and the persistent slab which I'm
Caption: sure you're all familiar with so what
Caption: does think urs suggest we should do well
Caption: basically it says we suggest split out
Caption: these two parts the right side and the
Caption: read side so now we have one stack over
Caption: here for a change in how their basis or
Caption: changing our persistence and one step
Caption: over here for reading from that database
Caption: I'm actually check the two levels here
Caption: because we may want to scale the unten
Caption: difference in the backend in terms of
Caption: number of instances and those we have
Caption: these two streams now basically we think
Caption: of these as the command and a query
Caption: string and on the left hand side for the
Caption: rights we have commands these commands
Caption: come in and tell the right side to
Caption: change something you know is this model
Caption: without the system sort and we have the
Caption: other side the query side we said hey I
Caption: want to find out something about it my
Caption: duplication to display our page and
Caption: reputation so forth so we clearly on
Caption: this side so two distinct stacks
Caption: separate from each other at the moment
Caption: they're sharing the same relational
Caption: database all that we'll see how that
Caption: change and in it because we have these
Caption: two separate stacks we can also now have
Caption: two separate models only modeled here
Caption: how we represent this in our business
Caption: application object oriented model or
Caption: wherever you wish to use so of course on
Caption: the command side here we will do the
Caption: command model a model of our business
Caption: through our objects and so forth which
Caption: is only want to apply these commands to
Caption: its focus on exchanging the model but on
Caption: this side here in the query side we can
Caption: have a different model that query model
Caption: now what about changing the objects in
Caption: the business more this is now reading it
Caption: so maybe it can be a signal
Caption: not so much business logic on so much
Caption: complexity that's called the query or
Caption: the read Saipan and again two separate
Caption: stacks so if you think about it terms of
Caption: the object approach and also now examine
Caption: a Enterprise Architecture what sort of
Caption: commands can you have and the typical
Caption: banking application here you have a
Caption: deposit money command or a withdraw
Caption: money command when our interest command
Caption: or change owner commands these are
Caption: things to change our banking model on
Caption: the query side to be getting balance to
Caption: explain the balance on the page until
Caption: getting the owner or getting a
Caption: transaction list or getting the accounts
Caption: there's again just read sightings so
Caption: here command if you we have queries but
Caption: notice how they're very similar to what
Caption: you may have in an object-oriented model
Caption: with a bank account or something like
Caption: that
Caption: now the commands here are so the the
Caption: natural ones for bank accounts
Caption: lots of these are in deployed
Caption: applications we think in terms of crud
Caption: type stuff let's have a create address
Caption: command let's have an update address
Caption: command or a delete address command of
Caption: course retrieve you will not be a
Caption: command that would be a query but one
Caption: thing they do suggest in CQRS is you get
Caption: away from your sort of crud thinking and
Caption: start to think about task based commands
Caption: this is what actually the task will be
Caption: in spaces that the user has when you're
Caption: trying to learn this this command what
Caption: we're trying to do so for example we may
Caption: have normally update address is an
Caption: update of a cron approach but really
Caption: what's the intent of the user there are
Caption: they fixing an error in the dressed are
Caption: they actually moving to a new address or
Caption: changing it to a primary address you can
Caption: capture their something taped about the
Caption: command rather than attack that's just
Caption: changing the data and that can be very
Caption: valuable for you in your application
Caption: later on and in the CQRS approach so
Caption: it's not explicitly a policy to RS and I
Caption: recommend looking at task based commands
Caption: so how do we scale this approach well
Caption: it's nice now because we have these
Caption: separate parts we can scale them
Caption: independently so the right side maybe
Caption: not so much for the read side room is
Caption: the muscular selection we can scale
Caption: which will any more instances to handle
Caption: the load separate scaling we solved that
Caption: issue
Caption: having a balanced style architecture but
Caption: again still is a problem with our
Caption: relational database we have this
Caption: persistence bottleneck we can't scale
Caption: that easily and in terms of I want to
Caption: you've probably heard many times and
Caption: have the impedance mismatch getting our
Caption: objects from our relational database
Caption: fairly difficult to use hibernate or
Caption: other systems and they're complex and it
Caption: can be in you you want to actually just
Caption: deposit some money in the bank account
Caption: we have to grow the database get your
Caption: whole object we construct the object
Caption: maybe you related objects that are
Caption: connected to the whole object and what
Caption: we do is depositing ten dollars very
Caption: complex business logic is people deposit
Caption: but you had to get all of this creating
Caption: the object here and building a complex
Caption: model just to do something simple and
Caption: simply avoid the creamy side here you
Caption: may have a different level or suggests
Caption: which is simpler so you can change the
Caption: model to match what is needed so there's
Caption: this bottle bottleneck in the
Caption: persistence to so it make some progress
Caption: we're scaling our reasons and right as
Caption: necessary but still the problem with the
Caption: relational database so again going quite
Caption: quickly here on it that's okay people
Caption: pulling ok we're doing well so the
Caption: second part of storing is any new music
Caption: by IP Ural events sourcing and it sounds
Caption: quite complex and difficult but that's
Caption: just a different way of persisting your
Caption: information your state and we'll explain
Caption: this one way you may understand it
Caption: better is if you think of a simple
Caption: example making an application for
Caption: purchasing concert tickets so your
Caption: simple object model or data model with
Caption: being a concept entity which has the
Caption: details about the content of the price
Caption: never take an entity which is a buyer
Caption: details in the ticket number of course
Caption: the concert can have many tickets so how
Caption: we how we use this in your application
Caption: when we start to put up a content with
Caption: certain price and certain details we
Caption: sell some tickets to disable to the
Caption: ticket store or the database or so forth
Caption: and we going fine it's been table in
Caption: there so discount the price to the
Caption: concert because we're knocking off sale
Caption: so if it's counter prior to the concert
Caption: by changing it and now it's lost some
Caption: information because we have those
Caption: customers who bought tickets already
Caption: they pay the
Caption: price we've changed the price here so
Caption: now we no longer know what price they're
Caption: paying and similarly if customers buy
Caption: some tickets and then cancel those
Caption: tickets so we delete the records we lose
Caption: the information about those purchases
Caption: and debt cancellation of tickets so in
Caption: our traditional data model where we
Caption: represent the data as a model in our
Caption: persistence and its current state we're
Caption: actually losing a lot of data every day
Caption: we are losing information that we have
Caption: we visceral way because we override it
Caption: in our database or in our store
Caption: we're losing data so how do we handle it
Caption: how can we maintain these extra
Caption: information which can be very useful for
Caption: the business what can we do if we look
Caption: at other similar solutions to similar
Caption: problems for example in accounting
Caption: systems may I just keep the final
Caption: balance of the account they keep all the
Caption: debits and credits along the way and
Caption: they work out the final balance when
Caption: they need to or keep it as a solute
Caption: temporary State they maintain the
Caption: transaction to record all the details
Caption: similarly in our file systems work these
Caption: days and databases of these dates they
Caption: use a right to head look so basically
Caption: log everything that's done basically for
Caption: even that they're more reliable and
Caption: robust if they have crashes but they're
Caption: keeping all this information in a wider
Caption: headlock and similarly if you look
Caption: inside databases and particularly
Caption: database replication they use this same
Caption: sort of approach they're going to send
Caption: update events which record everything
Caption: happens in the system rather than just
Caption: the current state of the database so
Caption: situation with your head sourcing tries
Caption: to following its leaves and says rather
Caption: than just keeping the state let's track
Caption: the changes to that state or events that
Caption: happen so rather than just having our
Caption: events which come in the commands slow
Caption: and come in and change the state our
Caption: commands are going to produce events so
Caption: we bought a ticket at this price event
Caption: so we change the price of the concerts
Caption: of angle someone council dick tickets
Caption: events we're going to remember every bit
Caption: of information in some sort of event
Caption: lock we store these events not the
Caption: domain state I'll show you it soon how
Caption: we can rebuild
Caption: the main state but we store these
Caption: defendants not the statement when we
Caption: come and we update the domain states
Caption: probably events as needed but most
Caption: importantly we don't update the domain
Caption: stator to imposition that event because
Caption: what is the system the event now we know
Caption: you can lose all our domain state we can
Caption: rebuild our system for all of these
Caption: events so we saved you there first and
Caption: then we can change our business state
Caption: and later on if you want to actually
Caption: rebuild our business State Department of
Caption: our memory representation of our data
Caption: model we can go through these events
Caption: again and rebuild the state just what
Caption: you meant through the debits and credits
Caption: in an account to find a balance so we
Caption: can very easily rebuild the state from
Caption: the events so this is event sourcing
Caption: saving the events that happen not just
Caption: the state of your application so
Caption: characteristics of events they're
Caption: immutable they never change when you
Caption: create an event something happened it
Caption: doesn't change it's a piece of history
Caption: they are still be stored in a pen only
Caption: storage you never need to update an
Caption: event because it's immutable and you can
Caption: play event as I mentioned we use the
Caption: mini event sorting to rebuild as a
Caption: domain state and save our main state but
Caption: events can also be used
Caption: I'll show you later on for managing
Caption: processes inside applications signaling
Caption: process states and integration between
Caption: subsystems in our application so events
Caption: are very useful to use these days and
Caption: more and more applications that are
Caption: coming event-driven so this event
Caption: sourcing fits in well with that it also
Caption: gives us the chance to order things and
Caption: allows us to do analytics because there
Caption: are whole sequencing eventually to
Caption: analyze our system rather than
Caption: separately creating logs and building
Caption: event streams so this is the general
Caption: approach and how does apply to our
Caption: concert tickets example or rather than
Caption: just directly saving the status whenever
Caption: a command comes in we would create these
Caption: events like the concert created the
Caption: ticket was ordered the ticket was
Caption: ordered the Christ was change our ticket
Caption: was ordered and using this state we can
Caption: look back to history and see when a
Caption: ticket was bought and what price it was
Caption: bought out before the price change
Caption: social weather
Caption: all of our information which is a very
Caption: valuable to do so the essence of course
Caption: is commands produce events commands come
Caption: in through our application we check the
Caption: command we produce the event and it's
Caption: saved somewhere in something like an
Caption: event or just a storage facility for
Caption: events and again this is a white-haired
Caption: log see is right there you actually
Caption: change them in there it's an append-only
Caption: storage system but that's the general
Caption: structure so what's the difference again
Caption: between these commands and it ends I
Caption: mentioned commands I pass clicks so
Caption: folks on what tasks is the command
Caption: trying to do isn't it come on asking you
Caption: to do something they often written an
Caption: active verb like do this will change
Caption: this commands can be rejected so command
Caption: comes in ask use to withdraw a million
Caption: dollars from our bank account so we
Caption: don't have a million dollars in your
Caption: bank account that command is rejected so
Caption: nautical commands are actually process
Caption: can be responded to and they can be lost
Caption: if someone you lose a command in the
Caption: process it's not so bad you can try it
Caption: again okay so it's okay believe me
Caption: commands that don't get processed in our
Caption: locks on the other side events events
Caption: are the things that it happens
Caption: there's fact so I mentioned your YouTube
Caption: so they never change and everything to
Caption: be changed
Caption: they often written in the past tense and
Caption: I mentioned their append-only
Caption: and there's no derived information from
Caption: of the events early information and they
Caption: cannot fail because there's something
Caption: attached now you've written into the
Caption: events or it happened there's no chance
Caption: of being rejected so and most post op in
Caption: event so that's a commands of events
Caption: here is that to that bank account
Caption: example he is showing you how they would
Caption: look into bank accounts deposit Ani
Caption: could be the command and then the
Caption: corresponding event in which you write
Caption: with me money deposited okay so this is
Caption: saying it happened and we've changed our
Caption: business data is up to date list all
Caption: money money withdrawn and interest
Caption: interest added set account details
Caption: account details set so there's nice
Caption: correspondence between the commands and
Caption: the events that record
Caption: as commands we have successfully
Caption: operated the houses actually work in the
Caption: application what's the sort of logic we
Caption: follow through so if you look in more
Caption: detail inside the application you have a
Caption: number of steps so the kalam counting
Caption: closely and the first thing you do is
Caption: check the command syntax is all the
Caption: right things are there in the command
Caption: and this is a superficial check it
Caption: doesn't require any business logic it's
Caption: just checking that everything's ok there
Caption: if it is then the rotating board
Caption: proceeding the second step there is to
Caption: validate the command with business logic
Caption: so now we need some business logic to
Caption: actually say is this an appropriate
Caption: command to actually process can we
Caption: protest that now a lot of commands are
Caption: just changing things there is a beauty
Caption: business logic so in the majority of the
Caption: cases you can just go ahead and do the
Caption: commands I need to worry then the
Caption: example I mentioned the withdrawn
Caption: limited dollars from a bank account you
Caption: would have to construct your business
Caption: state here if I have what is the balance
Caption: for the bank account before I can either
Caption: accept this command and do it or not so
Caption: if it was I mean the envelop a bank
Caption: account is the same if there wasn't I
Caption: would reject this command so you're only
Caption: building up your object State or your
Caption: business State as you need it to
Caption: validate the commands it's not building
Caption: up everything you just need to do what
Caption: you need to do if we do evaluate the
Caption: commands business logic and we move on
Caption: to the next step and the next step is
Caption: now right that you need throughout the
Caption: system store we have approved that we're
Caption: going to do it now and once that's
Caption: written it's basically gospel it's done
Caption: ok so we can't change things but of
Caption: course writing the event to the event
Caption: store hasn't updated our business wall
Caption: so now we have a chance to update our
Caption: update our domain state in here to
Caption: change the bank account balance if you
Caption: want to or want to keep it in your
Caption: memory so these are the sort of steps
Caption: should go through when you're processing
Caption: a command and producing events in
Caption: everything crashed here no worries we
Caption: can come back here and read these events
Caption: together for showing the second and
Caption: reproduce that state so once we have
Caption: written this event where sex is our
Caption: persistence mechanism now what our
Caption: relational database type store so I
Caption: mentioned then rebuilding the state so
Caption: the saving you is much important if we
Caption: do want to rebuild this
Caption: eval is apparently through that but we
Caption: just go through and read out the events
Caption: related to this particular bank account
Caption: or this particular concert lead through
Caption: the event and process those events to
Caption: find the final state the current status
Caption: now people often asked about this have
Caption: you a lot of events to go into and so
Caption: forth if you think about one particular
Caption: bank account is usually not that many
Caption: and also in the mechanism associative if
Caption: CQRS called snapshotting where is we
Caption: have a lot of events you can make a step
Caption: show the state just look like a summary
Caption: you don't delete the previous events but
Caption: now you have a something where you can
Caption: start off rather than going back to this
Caption: first event this is actually quite
Caption: efficient and quite fast and not
Caption: difficult to do so we want to read their
Caption: well is the state to do something with
Caption: it to apply some complex logic we can
Caption: actually read the event and rebuild
Caption: those and then update the main state so
Caption: there's some that work since so this is
Caption: basically the CQRS
Caption: architecture let's say two streams two
Caption: sacks one the query time on the right
Caption: side we produce cones over here you give
Caption: us events in a big store and we have a
Caption: query side over this side now release
Caption: modern architecture it's an
Caption: architectural pattern so you shouldn't
Caption: think of it as being the architecture
Caption: for your whole application it's more a
Caption: part of your application which in
Caption: colleges collaboration which means this
Caption: sort of scaling may use this approach if
Caption: you think it's appropriate so it's an
Caption: architectural pattern I want to break
Caption: the pattern down again just to show you
Caption: a bit more of how it actually works and
Caption: what different parts relate to each
Caption: other so the first step we saw was
Caption: producing commands on the right side so
Caption: this is the part of the staff that does
Caption: that basically the commands come in we
Caption: validate the commands and then we wipe
Caption: them to the event store and update is
Caption: that update out of state if necessary so
Caption: whenever you're making a change to your
Caption: business on this side this is a part of
Caption: the applications that use the other side
Caption: doesn't evenly come into it so it's a
Caption: bit different than traditional
Caption: applications because then you put a
Caption: request in here you're sending to use
Caption: command what you get back you don't get
Caption: back an answer saying here's the final
Caption: balance or here's the new state you just
Caption: get back an answer saying yes we
Caption: received your command and it's validated
Caption: maybe not even that so it's a bit of
Caption: different to architecture
Caption: in fact the next state of your
Caption: application the next day of your page
Caption: we'll talk more about this later on but
Caption: this is the process commands on the
Caption: right side approach come on the enduring
Caption: events safer than the event store so how
Caption: do we get this other side of our
Caption: application the read side updated well
Caption: there's a separate part here which is
Caption: sort of like responsible for taking our
Caption: events and updating our website so we
Caption: have all our people to be pull into the
Caption: event store we have any event handler
Caption: here which is listening for these events
Caption: and when the events getting to there is
Caption: sort of notifying it takes the event and
Caption: it updates our web store this is very
Caption: independent and separate from the right
Caption: side so if some application code here
Caption: running which is listening to this and
Caption: updating this when it can all use the
Caption: taneous leaders when it came when it
Caption: gets around to it and we'll mention that
Caption: type it later on so that's the second
Caption: step and the third part of the
Caption: architecture is just this query site and
Caption: as you can see the query site is much
Caption: simpler now but it is just reading
Caption: information so a clearly comes in this
Caption: function handles it and basically goes
Caption: to database to get to the information
Caption: returns so there's no there complex
Caption: operations or building object models
Caption: it's just getting the data and returning
Caption: it you can do more complex models but in
Caption: the simplest way we can do this the
Caption: benefit of this is we can have multiple
Caption: view schools so now when your
Caption: application used to scale and you will
Caption: actually be fast to provide baptists
Caption: information you can create abuse or
Caption: justly information unique to these
Caption: particular queries because remember you
Caption: have something on the back end here
Caption: which can update any particular view
Caption: store you make so you can have multiple
Caption: views stores
Caption: providing responses to particular
Caption: periods and even better you can add
Caption: these two at a later stage so maybe
Caption: you're going on if you are it's getting
Caption: very slow in my queries are too slow I
Caption: need a rest database you can add an
Caption: extra graph database in here if you've
Caption: got a bit later on that's fine a graph
Caption: database in here and still that great
Caption: graph database up based upon the events
Caption: you have stored so now quickly respond
Caption: to queries that would use a graph
Caption: database spirit to respond than a
Caption: traditional database so having multiple
Caption: review stores allow you to
Caption: to the query to a few stories to make
Caption: the website very efficient and a very
Caption: powerful
Caption: that's the third tip so the important
Caption: thing here is again separating these
Caption: commands on the right side from the
Caption: queries or the read side when we do the
Caption: commands you only need to rebuild the
Caption: application state necessary to validate
Caption: that business logic you can actually
Caption: keep the application state allmate you
Caption: need to understand few actually need
Caption: four particular commands and on the
Caption: Prairie side we only reveal the
Caption: application state enough to do some
Caption: business logic to read and return the
Caption: data but we can even make sure the query
Caption: model doesn't even need any business
Caption: project it just returns the data from
Caption: the group for the query so this is our
Caption: most important deceleration here as I
Caption: mentioned any query side we can have
Caption: district data source so basically we
Caption: have SQL standard one we have a graph
Caption: database or a document database and we
Caption: can update these as needed so they match
Caption: the queries and we can do D
Caption: normalization so you have a complex user
Caption: interface which means lots of different
Caption: objects rather happen to build all these
Caption: objects up and make sure you can query
Caption: look you actually do normalize the
Caption: database produce a new score which
Caption: exactly matches your query and now it's
Caption: very quick to respond to which is what
Caption: we do often with caching and so forth a
Caption: caching stores basically that if the
Caption: cache of these complex build up
Caption: responses to queries and the cache them
Caption: we can think of these is like a fiddle
Caption: attached which is made for just what we
Caption: need to do so again this is our most
Caption: important part the view side the queries
Caption: can be tailored to what you need in your
Caption: application to scale well so again they
Caption: are here the CQRS subsystem and here's
Caption: our different databases we have a graph
Caption: database now in a relational database so
Caption: now in the events come true they update
Caption: both of their status tools as necessary
Caption: we want the code to update these 8.1
Caption: events happen and they will mimic what
Caption: we need query comes in we can get both
Caption: on there we have the stream handler to
Caption: update this one and we have the
Caption: processes I think the other one so event
Caption: handler is
Caption: both so this is the general architecture
Caption: and I hope that gives you a quick feel
Caption: for what it's like being very quick
Caption: there just to show you a couple of
Caption: further power things you can do in the
Caption: architecture this is another diagram
Caption: which tries to represent the
Caption: architecture up here you've got the
Caption: command side going through yes I mean to
Caption: get your command hardwood handlers here
Caption: to validate the commands you build up
Caption: your domain model the storing your
Caption: events here here you have any meant bus
Caption: so the events can actually respond that
Caption: you can make changes in your domain or
Caption: scale in a second on the query side here
Caption: when the events come across we can
Caption: update our data source and now we
Caption: clearly here with a thin layer our data
Caption: stores but you may also have analysis
Caption: databases then where all your events are
Caption: producing analytics these savings are
Caption: big a big data analytics we can have
Caption: live updating on our analytics fest
Caption: because the events can be used to
Caption: manipulate the analytics views and so
Caption: many things here like sending an email
Caption: when an event comes out you can send an
Caption: email out a different form of the
Caption: response to event on the query side so I
Caption: can get quite complex and powerful this
Caption: sort of architecture the interesting
Caption: thing in a more complex thing about this
Caption: is we have a notion of eventual
Caption: consistency because the right side is
Caption: separate from the read side intestinal
Caption: while for these events to trickle across
Caption: to the reader either for the read side
Caption: to be updated so the ringside may not
Caption: instantaneously represent the value
Caption: having your business data if it's a
Caption: problem or possibly not because once you
Caption: read something from your database its
Caption: instantaneously out a day anyway unless
Caption: you've locked availables something could
Caption: change the day behind you so it's a
Caption: matter of degrees here we're sort of
Caption: meeting that nadir is always somewhat
Caption: stale it's always going to take a while
Caption: that will always eventually be
Caption: consistent so immediately consistency
Caption: can take a problem it requires a change
Caption: in thinking how you approach things and
Caption: thinking about transactions thinking
Caption: about user interfaces and you can see
Caption: the differences in a couple of examples
Caption: some traditional web flow you submit a
Caption: form to an application becomes like data
Caption: and your response
Caption: the results the new state of the
Caption: application responding to that data
Caption: listen submitter the deposit in a bank
Caption: account get your new data back it's the
Caption: balance of that bank account this
Caption: situation can't do that you submit a
Caption: command request you just get the command
Caption: results or that okay if that command is
Caption: okay to actually find out the balance of
Caption: the bank account you have to have to
Caption: submit a query and get the data back and
Caption: if you submits a query exactly the same
Caption: time or just after you submit the
Caption: command the results you get back maybe
Caption: the old balance because the data hasn't
Caption: rippled across to the new side yet you
Caption: have to start thinking about this in how
Caption: we handle our user interfaces what we
Caption: display will be expect to see you may
Caption: see a lot of community faces do say
Caption: their little speed wheels for a while
Caption: away what I would do a lot box if you've
Caption: been displaced a second to get the data
Caption: refresh on the read side to produce the
Caption: updated data but this generally uses a
Caption: problem so options we have here we can
Caption: wait until the website updates we can
Caption: decline and pull though your read side
Caption: see whether it's been updated we can
Caption: signal the read side to tell it when
Caption: it's updated so it dissuades around
Caption: forgives the signal or we can take the
Caption: client so the client pretends like it
Caption: went through okay it gives us what the
Caption: interface would look like we fake it
Caption: until we find out something wrong we
Caption: correct it so there are some options
Caption: there to handle this eventual
Caption: consistency there are a couple of our
Caption: interesting case studies of this which
Caption: I'll just briefly touch on but all of
Caption: the grocery still this one is when you
Caption: set up an account for registering here
Caption: so you'll come over to your user
Caption: interface you're typing either choosing
Caption: a username and submitting that username
Caption: so when we actually find out and type in
Caption: that username and is submitted
Caption: in the time since we've submitted it
Caption: someone may actually create that
Caption: username so now command may not be
Caption: validated so how do we handle that well
Caption: we can try and handle the situation
Caption: where someone shows in the exact same
Caption: username as someone exactly a couple of
Caption: microseconds before them chose a
Caption: username which is what you may have to
Caption: do but generally speaking would be
Caption: easier to flag is a problem and fix it
Caption: up because it will be silent again
Caption: so agree at least to happen but that
Caption: could happen is the CTRs eventual
Caption: consistency
Caption: another example here is when you go into
Caption: a cafe and this shows the approach to
Caption: transactions individual consistency as
Caption: well you may be ordering a coffee need
Caption: from the cashier so you're doing here
Caption: and you basically submit your commands
Caption: the cashier leave order coffee and you
Caption: get a receipt that time you've got these
Caption: ordered and you go and sit down but you
Caption: don't know what's been happening the
Caption: back here when the cashier talks to
Caption: Bristol I'm a tile we run out of that
Caption: cotton you can't do that order and if it
Caption: was a complete transaction you will
Caption: ensure that all can happen at the same
Caption: time but in the real world we don't have
Caption: that problem we really have that problem
Caption: well they actually try to solve it with
Caption: transaction you know check everything
Caption: before we do the command in the real
Caption: world that actually would collect you
Caption: and say you haven't looked those coffee
Caption: would you like one of these you say sure
Caption: that's how immigrated with that so you
Caption: can make some adjustments afterwards
Caption: so this is the way to CQRS operates not
Caption: try to have a huge transaction but
Caption: handling these problems which make you
Caption: rare but handle them in a way which is
Caption: not a transaction oriented so if humans
Caption: do this we live in a world which is
Caption: eventually persistent we find out later
Caption: that there wasn't a coffee rather than
Caption: at the time of purchase and we came to
Caption: get along okay so maybe we should make
Caption: systems more like this so we can make
Caption: systems more like this rather than to
Caption: like to make them totally consistent so
Caption: a couple of bits of a further look at
Caption: events inside see - ah referential
Caption: events are very important very useful
Caption: events can be used with event sourcing
Caption: I've talked about but also process
Caption: management and communication and
Caption: integration between social systems
Caption: the way we handle processes in CPRS and
Caption: having what's called targets or process
Caption: managers these are basically a different
Caption: type of thing we've seen so far we have
Caption: these command harmless command hardened
Caption: handlers in CQRS
Caption: a command handler takes a command
Caption: validates it produces an event process
Caption: managers of Sagas are a bit different
Caption: they basically respond to your bins and
Caption: produce commands so a project manager is
Caption: listening for an event and produce
Caption: c'mon which affect the system and using
Caption: this approach you can actually handle
Caption: processes or have complex processes in
Caption: your system I'll skip over this but this
Caption: shows us an example here of our process
Caption: manager we place an order and we get
Caption: back an order confirms response then
Caption: when it actually processes this order it
Caption: sends the command out to this particular
Caption: oil aggregate the order a group produces
Caption: an event which comes back the event is
Caption: recognized and now the project manager
Caption: produces another command and then
Caption: produces event our reservation was seats
Caption: were reserved on two but that events we
Caption: can't start to do a letter processing so
Caption: the process manager is basically sending
Caption: commands listening for events responding
Caption: to loaders sending about commands so it
Caption: allows us to coordinate complex
Caption: processes using these events and using
Caption: these commands so that's the idea here
Caption: cybers they listen for events and
Caption: produce commands of a meteor this is
Caption: also useful for subsystem integration so
Caption: if you have multiple subsystems in your
Caption: application how can you handle those
Caption: here's our split between our two
Caption: subsystems so this helps support system
Caption: over here is producing commands
Caption: receiving commands producing events
Caption: doing its business our other subsystem
Caption: over here can masada which is used
Caption: integration in this case which is
Caption: listening for events weather here's one
Caption: loaded it it can send a command into
Caption: each subsystem so now we can integrate
Caption: how different subsystems are using API
Caption: calls by by event-driven for the whole
Caption: system now become the agreement but it's
Caption: still separated the only interface is
Caption: through these events so that's another
Caption: new era we are useful sagas or project
Caption: managers and I'll skip over that there
Caption: obviously over this or even into play
Caption: tiem so pros and cons of CQRS approach
Caption: well it's very scalable it's very simple
Caption: to scale it's made to scalable it's very
Caption: cost-effectively cloud deployment
Caption: because each of these things can be
Caption: scaled separately not scaling one big
Caption: application they can scale the Reeb side
Caption: separately from the
Caption: website we can rapidly adapt to changing
Caption: business requirements we can change our
Caption: commands we can change the events very
Caption: easily so rapidly adapt to those the
Caption: corners were difficult side of these
Caption: things that if dimensional consistency
Caption: takes a little while to get your mind
Caption: around and this credit systems can be a
Caption: bit more complex many applications
Caption: rather one big awkward modeling
Caption: application and it does add some extra
Caption: complexity to your applications handling
Caption: these commands and it ends I haven't got
Caption: time to talk about in that store but you
Caption: can this is basically a storage way to
Caption: store events and the one I use is Greg
Caption: gallons in that store it particularly
Caption: made the story events and streams events
Caption: well I like to finish off with in just
Caption: the last 5 or 10 minutes is looking
Caption: about this question of how to assist
Caption: application state so traditionally with
Caption: this persistent state by files
Caption: relational databases and we tried object
Caption: going to databases that didn't work so
Caption: well they didn't take off and why was
Caption: that well people says maybe relational
Caption: database is a more natural way of
Caption: storing data which is independent of our
Caption: other applications paradigm whether it's
Caption: object-oriented or functional or
Caption: traditional procedure application
Caption: relational is a sort of timeless way of
Caption: storing data and that was pretty true
Caption: that's why relational databases where
Caption: they can stuck around longer than
Caption: object-oriented databases so the rest I
Caption: want to ask is any event sourcing help
Caption: us to store things in different ways
Caption: with the index or team you know enables
Caption: us to be white models that are necessary
Caption: to validate and perform the commands so
Caption: we can just focus on the needed model at
Caption: the need at a time we need it we can be
Caption: we can build three models which match
Caption: our queries so the events tool allows
Caption: you to be much more flexible in which
Caption: right models you have in which we'd
Caption: model should have just like relational
Caption: databases allow us to be more flexible
Caption: in what paradigm you use event sourcing
Caption: allowed be more flexible in what data
Caption: stores you use what models you use so I
Caption: think it's useful the way to take model
Caption: of our subsystems need situates if
Caption: you're building of the application this
Caption: subsystem may be complex it needs
Caption: ers the Preferences subsystem may be
Caption: very simple doesn't need situations so
Caption: how can you get the benefits of an event
Caption: store which is sort of I think a multi
Caption: parallel way of storing the data when
Caption: you don't need CTRs for the time so I
Caption: forgot this for a while I think there's
Caption: a number of alternatives here for
Caption: different alternatives of course if
Caption: you're doing 60 RS with event sorting
Caption: then you have your big sorting an event
Caption: store everything's okay you're storing
Caption: all your stuff in events stores you get
Caption: all the benefits but sometimes we don't
Caption: need all of these separate schools you
Caption: don't want to have if you don't need
Caption: this complexity of separate stores so a
Caption: simpler version of our sub system could
Caption: be let's drop the separate stores and
Caption: let's just have a back-end here which
Caption: creates one data model we use for the
Caption: write commute and also to the regroup
Caption: one your shared data model now so it's
Caption: simpler doesn't scale as well doesn't
Caption: match our very size and maybe for some
Caption: particular subsystems in your enterprise
Caption: application this would be good enough
Caption: what about even less than that what
Caption: about if we didn't actually even want to
Caption: use event sourcing we just wanted to
Caption: have two separate sites we're still
Caption: keeping the CQRS separation and we
Caption: didn't want to use event source and we
Caption: want to store our data in a shared data
Caption: store maybe a relational database you
Caption: may be a graph database here we could
Caption: still still do that as long as we saved
Caption: our event as well so we still process
Caption: our command up here and save our event
Caption: we just don't you use the events we
Caption: actually just respond in Norway official
Caption: application and the same can be said
Caption: with an application which didn't even
Caption: use secure we could have a traditional
Caption: application with some data stores no
Caption: separate reading right sides maybe your
Caption: subsystem doesn't need that separation
Caption: you can still take this approach hello
Caption: come on come in save the event I just
Caption: operate traditionally once you save the
Caption: event I think if you do this approach
Caption: for all your subsystems
Caption: make sure you store your events you then
Caption: have the flexibility to use the simpler
Caption: models but also the change between these
Caption: models that we start off with this
Caption: simpler application is what all yes
Caption: the subsystem mentor because we've
Caption: stored all the events we can go back to
Caption: this one okay okay we're going to have
Caption: separate or different database stores
Caption: now that can rebuild them if you find
Caption: you need to scale war you can go back to
Caption: this one and eventually you can go back
Caption: to this so as long as your architecture
Caption: has an ocean of commands in it and save
Caption: the events once you are validated it
Caption: doesn't matter what you use in your
Caption: subsystems it can be CQC GRS but it can
Caption: be a lot simpler you don't have to go to
Caption: full way so I think using an event
Caption: stored give us the flexibility to change
Caption: your architecture as we grow as we sail
Caption: when you're doing the application start
Caption: with you can just start with this
Caption: approach and later you could actually
Caption: change it to one of the others so the
Caption: benefits here you can change that that
Caption: will happen if you need it and when you
Caption: need you can use event for integration
Caption: across the subsystems event driven
Caption: systems great and we can use events for
Caption: analytics and data analysis from
Caption: real-time data analytics so basically I
Caption: think lots of benefits of that approach
Caption: in this approach the events tool becomes
Caption: your cool swords motor relational
Caption: database anymore is the immense tool
Caption: this is why I think the events or can be
Caption: the ultimate solution to persistence
Caption: don't this is just state but the sister
Caption: events we can use them for analytics we
Caption: can use them constructing our data
Caption: models we can use them for integration
Caption: we can change our architecture flexibly
Caption: as we go along
Caption: so that was a lot there hopefully it was
Caption: sensible if it saw what was happening
Caption: and in summary I guess we've seen a
Caption: number of things we've seen that CQRS
Caption: means separating the commands and the
Caption: queries the right models in the remodels
Caption: we've seen the events or seeing the
Caption: persisting events rather than domain
Caption: state directly it's a different way of
Caption: doing persistence we've seen that
Caption: secularists and it's resulting eventual
Caption: consistency which may sound strange to
Caption: the side but you can get around it it's
Caption: a livable and it actually works more
Caption: like the real world and we've seen
Caption: lastly that events may be the ultimate
Caption: in West timeless waves persist our
Caption: application state without actually
Caption: persisting the center resisting the
Caption: events and of course we have lots of
Caption: memory and lots of disk space to solve
Caption: is an X now so there's no problem
Caption: that we don't have this all the simple
Caption: safety so that's a quick orbit these
Caption: water resources here as you want to
Caption: share this life later do to get started
Caption: on this or 15 extra things and do then
Caption: check time the questions I'm happy to
Caption: answer any questions
Caption: that's a good one I said that sir you
Caption: say that if an important one actually
Caption: perform that kind of means you can't
Caption: really reproduce you educate the way
Caption: reliably the web was because maybe your
Caption: event at one photo now you know you you
Caption: you check the command pan Thompson's
Caption: first of all you validate the command
Caption: into the command a good command
Caption: validated check then you save the event
Caption: where there's a turn out if the actual
Caption: operation failed and we try it again
Caption: okay later we control we can rebuild the
Caption: system and try it again we have this
Caption: event store because they give you very
Caption: instantly I will in this problems there
Caption: if the system is not running and not
Caption: working we have a bigger problem I think
Caption: then isn't currently supposed estimate
Caption: conflict management someone I'm also
Caption: going to accept so I think it's
Caption: beautiful that the cart process the
Caption: event in time is coming out over the
Caption: line so that the validation is very
Caption: important by checking the bank balance
Caption: we have enough money in the bank to
Caption: actually perform this we're doing that
Caption: we can just write that event out your
Caption: gullet before you save sort of office
Caption: life is the way around you think you
Caption: think you do the command system all and
Caption: then say oh yeah what they can check
Caption: your work first of all okay any other
Caption: questions she's not thank you very much
Caption: for dinner